hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the grand inquisitor chapter of book
five
of the brothers karamazov ivan karamazov
in his poem the grand inquisitor has the
character of that name
talking to christ and explaining how
they are improving upon the divine plan
and
in some respect christ's poor
performance in making humankind
happy and part of what he's narrating
here
it bears upon tendencies within human
nature
that would have to be dealt with if
happiness
is going to be attained and it turns out
that happiness and freedom
are in many respects at least according
to the grand inquisitor
incompatible and he does so through the
lens
of the three temptations discussed in
the gospel narrative when christ
is out in the desert fasting for 40 days
and nights
and the devil comes to him and tempts
him in three ways the first way
had to do with bread christ would be
very hungry after 40 days fasting
the second has to do with something
different and here we move from you
might say
the purely earthly realm of human basic
needs for
things that satisfy our hunger our
thirst our need for shelter
all of those sorts of things to more
properly
spiritual matters
and in the miracle i'll just read you
the
passage that he has here he says that
when the dread and wise spirit that is
the devil set you on a pinnacle of the
temple
it takes christ all the way up to the
temple in jerusalem
and says if you would know whether or
not you are the son of god
cast yourself down for it's written of
him that the angels will bear him
up and he will not fall or be hurt and
then you'll know whether
you're the son of god and will prove
what faith you have
in the father so the devil is telling
christ
jump jump and the angels will catch you
it'll be
a miracle it will be a sign
that you are indeed the son of god
because you know it's even in scripture
right here
and christ says no i'm not going to do
that and
what's going on there this is being
interpreted by the grand inquisitor
as not just something that has to do
with christ and the devil
but something that has to do with what
christ will do
in relation to humankind and so
the grand inquisitor says that you heard
and rejected the offer you did not yield
and did not throw yourself down
in this you prac you acted proudly
and magnifice magnificently like god
so you're setting an example and he says
but mankind that weak rebellious tribe
are they gods you knew that if you made
just one step one movement
towards throwing yourself down you would
immediately have tempted the lord and
would have lost all faith in him
but uh you didn't do that are there many
like you
is this something that human beings are
actually
capable of and the grand inquisitor is
saying yes in fact some human beings
are capable of that but the majority of
them are not
the majority of human beings need
something
different and here he tells us this is
the transition
from the first temptation to the second
temptation
he says that the the question that that
humankind asks before
whom shall i bow down there is no more
ceaseless or tormenting care
for human beings so long as they remain
free then to find
someone to bow down to and it goes
beyond that though he says
the human being seeks to bow down before
that which is
indisputable so we don't just want to
bow down before
anything whatsoever maybe in terms of
getting bread
you know we'll bow down before somebody
were like that person's a real idiot a
scumbag but he feeds me so
you know just like you go into your work
and you're like my bosses are morons
but i get a paycheck right but when it
comes to things that matter more
to the human being than just being fed
we want there to be something like proof
we want to know
that we're bowing down to the right
thing
and we want to bow down together
we don't just want to bow down by
ourselves we want other people to join
in that bowing down he says that
here we go the pit the care of these
pitiful creatures is not just to find
something before which i or some other
person can bow down but to find
something that
everyone else will also believe in and
bow down to
for it must needs be all together
so long as you have your set of beliefs
and other people are doing something
different
and believing differently and maybe not
even believing in anything there's
always a little bit of doubt
in your mind you're like oh i don't know
if i'm on the right track
i really like if they would get on the
same page with me
and so what is a natural human tendency
what do we often do
with our freedom we fight we fight you
know
on twitter with words we fight with
sticks
we fight by engaging in in uh
you know almost genocidal actions
actually sometimes quite genocidal
actions
where belief is somehow tied to an
ethnicity
right and he says that this need for
commune
communality of worship is the chief
torment of each
human individually and of mankind as a
whole from the beginning of the ages
in the cause of universal worship
they've destroyed each other with the
sword
and here he's got a really interesting
passage he says
they have made gods and called upon each
other abandon your gods come and worship
ours
otherwise death to you and your gods
so you can say yeah those religious
people man they really
need to impose their their views on
everybody else
and this is where dostoevsky shows that
he's very attuned
to his own century in the century coming
afterwards because he says
that's not really about religion as such
people can abandon gods
they're still going to make other idols
so it's not just
gods as such he says even when all gods
have disappeared from the earth they
will still
fall down before idols
so they're still going to demand
absolute satisfaction of each other it
could be
the marketplace as idol you know
it's really sad that these people should
die so that we can open the economy but
you know they've gotta
gotta worship that idol it could be some
other thing about universal harmony
of human beings and the wonderful
utopian society we're going to produce
it could be the race
it could be the class it could be
whatever it is that you want it could be
some other made up nonsense it could be
worshiping science like the i ef and
love science people that were
putting out memes all the time before
and essentially treating science as an
idol we call that scientism right
people are willing to fight and kill
each other to impose
these things upon each other he's not
saying everybody is
some human beings won't some human
beings may not necessarily be
you know following christ but they're at
least saying i'm not going to
participate in this this bloodletting
this killing
this destroying of other human beings
this suppression
but most human beings are cool with that
according to the grand inquisitor
and you know when you look at situations
when everything starts to fall apart
it turns out that that may in fact be
the case
so there's fighting over
gods and idols he also talks about
another part which is handing over
their conscience right he says that
the human being is no more tormenting
care than to find someone who they can
hand over as quickly as possible that
gift of freedom
with which the miserable creature is
born
he alone can take over the freedom of of
people who appeases
their conscience he says with bread you
were given an indisputable banner give
people bread they'll bow down to you
there's nothing more indisputable than
bread you can look at it you can bite
into it
right he says but at the same time
someone else takes over his conscience
well then he'll throw away the bread
and pursue that
right follow him who has seduced his
conscience
and so you know he's saying christ what
you really ought to have done
is provided people with something
incontrovertible
to believe in you know he says human
beings
need a firm idea of what they live
for they do not live on bread alone they
need something
else and you failed to provide that to
all but to
a few you stressed freedom and love and
you know sort of willingly giving your
faith
you refused to perform miracles at
certain points
when you could have done so and thereby
you know put everybody under one banner
and appeased everybody's consciences and
made everybody
happy what you refused
are miracle mystery and authority
and you you could say well wait a second
i've read the bible
he turned you know loaves into fishes
and water into wine and
had a uh you know a blind person sea
and healed lepers and also you know uh
resurrected the dead i mean we've got an
account of that here
christ doing the same thing in uh the
grand inquisitor passage
what are you talking about the
difference is that christ
did miracles uh or signs as they're
called in the gospel of john
when he chose to he didn't just do it
all the time he wasn't like a miracle
dispensing
you know robot or something like that
which is what the grand inquisitor
is is really talking about so miracle
mystery and authority christ didn't
actually make use of these when he could
have said listen i'm god incarnate
everybody bow down worship and uh you
pharisees and sadducees
you're both wrong so shut the hell up
and get over here
he didn't do that he could have but he
didn't
he he did use mystery but the mystery
that he used is different than the
mystery of the grand inquisitor
and these
as the grand inquisitor says these can
be used
to hold firm the conscience
of human beings for their
happiness he says you can uh there's
only three powers on earth capable of
conquering and holding
captive forever the conscience of these
feeble rebels
miracle mystery and authority you christ
rejected the first the second and the
third
and gave yourself as an example
of that and that's an example that's
extraordinarily difficult to follow
only a few can do it we're not here just
for the few
we're here for the many we got to take
care of the flock like you said we're
shepherds
so we're doing a better job than you did
jesus
so you know he tells us that
you know humans want miracles
and they want miracles in some respect
more
than they want god he says that
you knew that your deed would be
preserved in books you hope that
following you
human beings would remain with god
having no need of miracles it's better
to believe
without miracles and to follow and he
says you did not know
that as soon as the human being rejects
miracles they will reject god as well
because the human being seeks not so
much god
as miracles and since human beings
cannot bear to be left without miracles
they will go and create miracles for
themselves their own miracles this time
and bow down to the miracles of quacks
eve though he be rebellious heretical
and godless 100 times
over you didn't come down from the cross
when they
shouted to you and said come down from
the cross and will believe that it's you
why not because jesus in you know
what he's presenting to human beings
again not kate not something that
everybody is necessarily capable of
he wanted to provide an example he
wanted to provide a path
that only a few would be strong enough
to follow unfortunately according to the
grand inquisitor
so human beings will make their own
miracles they will make their own things
that they believe in their own things
that captivate
their conscience again we can leave
behind religion
and find many people who have their own
secular versions
of these their own worldly versions
right which often have just as much
faith and dogma as any religious
position
what about mystery he rejects
the mystery that christ brings he says
if there were so many as are supposed to
be at the the resurrection
they were not like human beings but like
gods they endured your cross
they endured scores of years of hungary
and naked wilderness eating locusts and
roots
and you can point with pride to these
children of freedom of free love of free
and magnificent sacrifice
in your name but remember there were
only several thousand of them
what about the rest is it the fault
of feeble mankind they could not endure
with the mighty endured is it the fault
of the weak soul that it's unable to
contain such terrible gifts
could it really be that you came only to
the chosen ones and for the chosen ones
if so there's a mystery here and we
can't understand
it and he says if it is a mystery
we have the right to preach mystery and
to teach them it's not the free choice
of the heart that matters
not love but the mystery itself we get
to give them
mysteries we'll come up with our own
we'll substitute our mysteries for your
mystery which is incomprehensible
or if it is comprehensible only a few
people are getting it
not the masses finally
there is the issue of authority right
authority can also captivate conscience
and he says that
you know we're not with you we're with
him that is
the devil the the spirit that is you
know tempting christ
that is our secret we've been with him
eight centuries ago we took from him
what you indignantly rejected the last
gift he offered
uh and so we're going to talk about that
in a separate thing but authority
here's the segway into it authority is
another thing that can hold
people's conscience captive the grand
inquisitor and his colleagues and their
church
but really could be any other
institution that's going to do the same
sort of thing
take away human freedom get humans to
give up their human freedom because
they're weak
and confused and and quite frankly
degenerate
so that they can in they can all be made
happy
that is going to be done with miracle
mystery and
authority so this is the
second great temptation that christ
didn't take
but the grand inquisitor and his
organization
did follow out and think through
you